immerhin hätten ihre reportage machen
die brustimplantate krank und dort zu
sehen einige
kommentare
unter kritik
und die wird ganz im ganzen story
und vor anker mieter kredit auch sowie
befinden sich berechtigt und zwar
mal schiebt sich automatisch ist nicht
gleich ein bildung sehr schlecht
schlusswort danach sie
freigesprochen
diesen aufruf am ende mit aufforderung
an die zuschauer dass sie kommentieren
sollen ob sie den betroffenen kranken
wirklich glauben oder ob sie denken dass
es nur einbildung wäre finde ich absolut
bedenklich
das hat man sich eine bessere formuliere
das ist unglücklich formuliert sie von
mir definitiv nicht zu fuß so dass die
frau als auch die symptome böte sich
faktisch warte man weiß einfach nicht
100 prozentig mit sicherheit sind
implantate hat sutil sollte wissen ist
und eine
flugsteuer was glaube der druck könnte
gar zwischen implantat und symptom
für die reportage mit sechs frauen kreta
und jetzt
wieder dort wo sie wichtig dass klose
gleich
klappt wie für sich jacky 2010 schreibt
ich habe seit 22 jahren implantate ich
habe
über jahre ich würde kaum 1 genommen ich
bin mittlerweile in vielen eingeschränkt
es vor kurzem habe ich von gefahren und
haben im november termin in die
implantate zu entfernen und dort beim
wache schiebt leid habe ich dasselbe
auch erlebt
denn aber mehrheit von der rückblick
aber zurück wo sie die glaube deine frau
mit der symptome logisch wäre aber die
symptome vorhanden
sie stellen aber eigentlich aber der
zusammenhang in frack und das ist
nämlich genau dass man nämlich vorher
zum beispiel
am 19 juni uns gestimmt
ich bin ein mann 19 und hatte beinahe
dieselben symptome bis auf die schuppige
haut die die frau beschreibt bei mir
läuft es aber daran dass ich eine
schlafstörung hatte aber die
hauptursache war eisenmangel
wenn gibt so ein kommentar von bäderland
sieht das liegt am schluss und ja ich
glaube eine frauen logisch ein
fremdkörper und der kantine zu
komplikationen führen einige symptome
sprechen eigentlich für eine allergische
reaktion
das ist genau da ist
symptom sie mega und spezifisch und
teilweise diffus und kirchen eine
krankheit der ablaufen
autoimmunerkrankungen oder eine allergie
und das macht das ganze heute so
schwierig ich glaube das war einmal aol
stufe finden was es wirklich wenn es
menschen darüber gibt
und wie die richtige geforscht wird und
meine resultate schlussendlich denn sie
auch kommentare und
verstanden sei für die op es also
generell aber nicht für die exploration
sondern für die implantation es wird
durch vergrößerung und auf die
kommentare waren ja eigentlich
gewünschte werde
beispielsweise
ich verstehe nicht warum man sich so
brustimplantaten machen lässt es sind
alle frauen in diesem film wunderschön
ich hatte bis jetzt noch nie das gefühl
irgendetwas einem moment irgendetwas an
meinen größten machen zu wollen wir
begrüßen aber
noch
nicht machen
der leidensdruck wir dr im film
beschreibt die frau
ein grund wieso das sieht aus wie machen
wieso das sie bisher an der sieg ist das
optik das werk einer deformation sich
das werk mit hochburgen
der frau ihre grund größe krönten die
besser nachvollziehen wie wenige andere
frau dass sao paolo und
erfinden müsse die frauen nicht
verurteilen dieses angebot was geht vom
markt und ich finde dass das angebot so
gemacht werden dass man auch gut
aufgelegt und ausruhen und da dass man
sie aber nicht aus gesunde frauen kranke
frau gemacht wenn man aber jetzt
thematisiert hat was der grund ist wie
so dass man jetzt bis heute prüft macht
oder aber nicht ich 1000 ganz anderen
fokus von der reportage und das gar
nicht wird in unserer bio eigentlich
denn sie noch fragen in europa kosten
und zwar steht k wer trägt die kosten
der exploration ich hoffe nicht dass die
gemeinschaft diese lifestyle ob gesunde
junge frauen auch noch übernehmen muss
es ist tatsächlich so dass nicht
selbstverständlich ist dass eine
krankenkasse zahlen will aber nicht
offiziell anerkannt ist krankheit noch
mit ihrer arbeit ingrid könnte frau
samuelsson wofür mandat für frauen wo
probleme mit ihren brustimplantaten
unbedingt
aber süchtige problem was übrigens hilfe
sind wie man dort und seit
es ist nicht selbstverständlich dass
krankenkassen einzahlen was ich nicht
offiziell als krankheit
es
ruft
die idee das aber sehe ob sie
beispielsweise gehabt stellte
krankenkasse dann kannst du bitte
krankenkasse was seite gutachter die
halo vertrauens also das ganze
berge und dabei ich schätze und wenn der
gutachter
skeptisch gegenüberstanden
tatsache sei der höchste vertreter
nation hat
mit der unicredit glück kompetenten ist
in
oberhof oder alexa und vor der natalie
vom verein
risiken schweiz
das von frau rost über hochkant serben
müssen deutsche recht interessant die
antwort zum zeitplan schreibt naja
drogen und zigaretten zahlt man auch
selbst und wenn man davon krank wird die
krankenkassen die behandlung sehr den
unterschied nicht
legitime argumentation
investiere brauche
wenn sie ihre themen potro wie zum
beispiel dass wir reportage machen thema
der long beach übrigens in der making
noch bevor die kommentare vor einer so
sie also bliebe träume und abonnieren
sie verpassen nichts